this program is brought to you by Emory
University
it takes a lot of out of if you think
about your your worst day is far as
fatigue think about the worst are the
most tired you've ever been in your life
multiply by 20 and think of it every day
well that's what we have to live with so
yes every now and then we are entitled
to our little pity party but the smart
thing and the best thing for us is not
let it linger have your moment pass it
on get past it keep it moving
get over there get up do something you
know you really do want people to
understand that sometimes it is because
look this is hard and it's you get
depressed and you do get below and you
cannot be in this much pain every day
and it not taking its toll on you
psychological impulses and so it's good
to have a good support system around you
I have some laughs friends and their job
is specifically when I call you all I
want you to do is make me laugh so they
will be funny with me they'll give me
that job but you cannot Lucas will
isolate you so that you cannot stay by
yourself for a long period of time
you've got to get around people that
understand the disease the family loves
you your friends support you but they
don't understand what it's like to live
with the disease until you talk to
another lupus person I mentioned to
somebody before about my mattress I make
sure that I have a mattress on my bed
that I don't like I really don't like it
I will sleep on it but it's not one of
those good cozy mattress is making
nothing and never want to get up because
for us if we're already feeling bad it
didn't take much to say I'm not getting
up so I leave that mattress there so
that at some point no matter how rocky
that road is or how bad I feel that
morning
I know I'm getting up because I can't
stand this mattress I'm gonna get up and
that's one of the things I the family
catches me in bed all day then they get
concerned they know it's
really wrong or otherwise I'm out of bed
you gotta get up and so that's how my
day begins it might take me a little
longer some days but I tried not to stay
in bed past 10:00 if I'm going to bed on
the 10th I'm really really not feeling
well
you
the preceding program is
University